but you as an intelligent person who is
also an atheist who thinks very deeply
about things
what do you cling to as a purpose for
life
do you have one do you have like when
you sit and think what's the point of
all this do you do you I don't have a
single one I don't have a monolithic
purpose I have plenty of
intermediate-sized purposes right
otherwise you know why continue living I
think that there's plenty of things I
want to do to achieve to experience to
share to give to the world right that's
a big feature right they give to the
world that you are your inner the way
you interact with other human beings and
your effect on other human beings gives
you gives you purpose yeah and even if I
think that when I die I will no longer
exist and my feelings won't matter I
have feelings right now about what the
world would be like even after I'm not
here anymore
right so I can still be motivated to
make the world a better place in ways
that will outlive me even if I think
that when I die it's really the end for
me hmm
and do you get down sometimes do you
ever do do you get like these periods of
like you like what is the purpose of all
this especially if you see some
ridiculous thing in the news or some
horrific tragedy and I'm pretty I mean
so for horrific tragedies no you know
I'm just you know fortunate enough to be
pretty even-keeled when it comes to that
stuff I don't have I don't struggle with
depression or despair or existential
anxiety or anything like that
when I was a kid when I was you know
first starting to think about the
universe and and science and things like
that I would start wondering about what
if the universe hadn't existed at all
what if I weren't wasn't here then that
maybe lose sleep that night and I think
like many people there was a very
definite moment when I realized that I
and everyone I knew would die right and
that so I woke up crying and my mom had
you know
Comfort me because like I was like you
know grandmom's gonna die and you're
gonna die I'm gonna die and you know
yeah but you know as it grown up no I
think that uh you know I'm more or less
so one again one of the future podcast
guests that I'll be next week's podcast
will be by a woman who's part of the
death positive movement have you heard
about this yeah so don't distinguish
don't don't confuse it there is a whole
movement like an anti natal this move or
something like that for you what they
call themselves but it's a whole
movement that once human beings not to
exist that's crazy yeah but there are
people who like that the death positive
movement is the following like we're
gonna die we should face up to it we
should accept it and we should deal with
it in a personally and culturally
positive way so for example right now
especially in the United States even
compared to Europe or other countries
we're terrible at dealing with death we
put people in hospitals we take them
away from their families away from their
homes we refuse to admit that they're
gonna die so we treat it as if the whole
purpose of the game is to squeeze out as
many more hours of life as possible no
matter what the quality of that life is
and all that it's just rubbish and we
should be much more grown-up about it we
should plan ahead you know when Obama
suggested that in the health care system
there should be you know some planning
for what happens when you die Sarah
Palin came along with death panels that
was a very effective rhetorical strategy
we don't want to think about the fact
that we're gonna die we don't want to
plan for it if we did plan for it it
could be better we could die at home we
could die with less pain we might not
live as long as we don't like do every
single medical intervention possible
just to squeeze out a few more breaths
but it could be a much more
[Music]
life-affirming experience to die because
the people around us who are there come
across with an acceptance of what's
going on rather than the feeling that we
should just do everything we can to
prevent I had a similar situation
happened recently with a dog
mine who's a mastiff reached 13 years
old and from Mastiffs that's very old
and we had to put him down because he
couldn't walk anymore
and he was it was brutally painful to
watch him try to get up and I fall down
and you know but one of the things I was
thinking was that if this is my
grandfather and not my dog I would have
to watch him suffer
until the bitter end yeah I knew this
dog wasn't going to go backwards in time
and become a puppy again right and knew
his days were numbered he couldn't do
anything most days he just slept all day
until it was time to eat but it was
getting to the point where I had to
carry him to his food yeah and I knew
that it was there's no quality of life
right no quality of life in some sense
is even harder with the dog because you
can't talk to them right you can't
explain to them what's going on they
can't explain to you what their wishes
are so you have to be the responsible
one
but yeah so everything legally and
culturally in the United States is we're
not allowed to relieve that pain or that
that despair that you have in the end of
your life some states including
California are passing Death with
Dignity laws where basically it's what
used to be called assisted suicide but
we don't call it that anymore you a
doctor is allowed to give you the means
to end your own life when you're when
you're near you have to be near a point
of no return but still clearly thinking
enough to be able to make that decision
for yourself and there's also an issue
with our real concern is their fear and
their this this experience being this
terrifying sort of step into the great
beyond
and there's a tool to mitigate that and
the tool that has been shown to mitigate
that as psychedelics one of the big ones
being psilocybin psilocybin has a
remarkable effect on people that are
going through stage four cancer and
Johns Hopkins has studied it there's
there's there's quite a few studies that
have shown that people when you give
them psilocybin
they're much more relaxed and much more
comfortable with this idea of ending
this life of this life you know it's
gone through its course and yet it's
it's an inevitable thing and it's really
our biological limitations that are
terrified and and and it's sparking up
all these intense primal fears of the
end yeah I'm actually 100% in agreement
there my wife Jennifer will let who is a
science writer wrote a book called me
myself and why searching for the science
of self and one of our friends said oh
if you're gonna write a book about the
self you gotta do LSD and so we did and
she researched it and it's a fascinating
history right and he'll dis Huxley I
don't know if you know about your story
and he took LSD to do exactly this he's
had throat cancer and it completely
helped yeah it's never fun to die right
but it absolutely helped ease that
journey in a very simple way but just as
we are a sort of immature society that
doesn't want to face up to the reality
of our eventual deaths we're also very
culturally conservative and squeamish
about drugs right and so we don't even
let people do research on some of these
drugs and so I think that yeah we have a
lot of growing up to do when it comes to
not just living a good life but also
having a good death and also paying
attention to actual scientists who study
these compounds and really understand
what the effects of them are and and
have researched them deeply and have
personal experiences with them and
they're saying well these these things
have been demonized yeah and there are
tools that we can use to sort of
mitigate a lot of the real issues that
we have whether it's culturally or
personally with these transitionary
times like death is inevitable so now
that we know it's inevitable you tell me
what the main problem would be with
someone taking psilocybin before they
die and letting them ease their way
through this but you know it's the same
reaction that doesn't want people to
have a basic income right there is a
sort of moral